breaking news just coming to us we were
talking a little while ago about the
possibility of some conservative MPs
leaving the party to join the new
independent group three of them have
just announced they will those three are
perhaps no surprises and as sue Bri
Heidi Alan and Sarah Williston a Sarah
Williston has just released a statement
in the last few moments she says with
regret I've decided to resign the
Conservative Party whip I'm passionate
about my constituency and have proud to
be the first conservative parliamentary
candidate to be selected by a full open
postal primary she talks about that
she's made the case for a centrist
moderate and outward looking approach to
politics and will continue to do so as
an MP but she says at a national level
the Conservative Party appears to have
abandoned attempts to modernize or to
broaden its appeal and has become less
tolerant and more inward looking I can
no longer remain a member of a party
whose leadership has so been driven by
the demands of the ERG and the DUP I did
not share their right-wing values or
those of the UKIP's supporters who've
been urged to join the Conservative
Party for aggressive and well-funded
social media campaign so this is a
statement from Sarah Willison outlining
some of the reasons why she has decided
to leave the Conservative Party she says
the final straw has been the
government's mishandling of brexit
despite the PM losing her majority no
meaningful attempt was made to reach out
to Hill divisions left by the referendum
all seek across party or national
consensus well let's bring in Kate
McAndrew who's still in central lobby in
the houses of parliament for us Kate I
mean these three names and a Seabury
Heidi Alan Sarah Williston they are all
people who have been openly critical
haven't they of the government and a
Seabury in particular a supporter of a
second referendum that's right and in
fact those are the three names that we
were just talking about about five
minutes ago speculating that they might
be the MPs to leave the Conservative
Party and in fact all three of them
Heidi Allen Sarah Williston and Anna
Seabury have now released
statement saying as you said there that
they can no longer remain in the
Conservative Party and this is a
significant moment for Teresa May as
Prime Minister not only is she now
fighting to keep her brexit her country
together she's also fighting to keep her
party together over brexit and as you
say there these three MPs have held very
strong views on the direction the Prime
Minister has taken when it comes to
leaving the European Union and a soupery
in particular has been outspoken
suggesting there needs to be much more
conversation with the party with
different wings of the party and
particularly with her grouping we really
strongly disagree with what Teresa May
is pursuing and we were talking earlier
about the difference of opinion between
the two sections of the party's
backbenchers the ERG the European
research group and Anna Sabri and others
like Dominic grieve who've consistently
tried to amend legislation that's gone
through the House of Commons to try and
persuade the prime minister to perhaps
think again about the direction that she
has taken now those three have clearly
decided that they are unable to stay in
the Conservative Party any longer and
now will leave the party and join that
independent group now that boosts the
number of MPs in that group that makes a
significant difference to them but it
also makes it harder for Teresa May to
get legislation through the Commons and
that's not to say she didn't already
face a struggle because these MPs never
really agreed with what she was seeing
in the first place but at least when
they were inside the Conservative Party
they were subject to the party's
whipping system that means the
disciplinary system the system the party
uses to ensure all its mp's vote in the
same way and they could rely effectively
on the number of MPs in their party to
try and back that legislation now that
is not going to be the case for the
prime minister anymore and she will just
be about to walk into the chamber to
face Prime Minister's Questions home
which is exactly not where she wants to
be when three of her MPs have just
walked off her benches what will be
really interesting to see is whether
these three now sits in the House of
Commons whether they attend
Prime Minister's Questions or whether
they choose not to do that because that
will make a really big stir and it will
also cause frustration among MPs and the
party who were already really deeply
concerned about splits and about the
implications of that for the
Conservative Party going forward